there's this guy mark lamont hill and
chris you had a rather spectacular
incident with this guy so he he's a big
progressive lefty he's got a show on
some network or something i want to
throw to this clip
of you on his show and the reason i'm
doing this on our fourth of july show is
because your defense of what really is
american in the face of sort of the
accusations of racism is just absolutely
perfect
name something positive that you like
about being white
well sure i i you know i'll i'll answer
with uh with a thing there
there's a lot of documents that are
floating around public schools that say
things like uh timeliness showing up on
time is a white supremacist value or a
white value white dominant value things
like rationality things like the
enlightenment things like uh you know uh
objectivity and uh these are very
strange things to be ascribed to a
racial identity my view is that these
are actually should be ascribed to every
individual human being every individual
human being regardless of whatever
racial category we impose on them
that doesn't answer that that doesn't
answer the question though
you're telling you're you're telling me
you're making strongmen about things
that are ascribed to whiteness that you
think are wrongfully ascribed to
whiteness i'm saying if whiteness isn't
a negative thing and there's something
that you actually and that whiteness
actually shouldn't be constructed as
all-negative name something positive
about being that you believe is positive
about being white
again i don't buy into the framework
that the world can be reduced into these
metaphysical categories of whiteness and
blackness i think that's wrong i think
we should look at people as individuals
i think we should celebrate uh different
people's accomplishments i think of
myself as an individual human being with
my own capabilities and i would hope
that we could both judge each other as
individuals
and come to common values on that basis
fair enough
fair enough chris i often say on the
show that when you hear something true
these days it's just so refreshing
because everything is just such layered
nonsense all the time but that clip uh
you know
imagine if you had said the reverse to
him uh and that's what i think people
are fed up with and i've had enough with
uh america individual it's all pretty
individualism it's pretty good right
that's right and i think the debate and
uh that he was trying to lay for me was
for me to buy into the same framework
that maybe he has bought into reducing
people to racial categories pitting them
against one another in this kind of
eternal conflict
and look that's how the world worked for
most of its history and it's actually a
magical thing that we've been able to
transcend it as much as we have i think
we still have a way to go um we need to
kind of depolarize and rise above some
of these divisions in this country but i
think we can do it and i think that we
have done it and we shouldn't let people
like mark lamont hill drag us back down
and whoever you are if you are black
white asian latino straight gay let's
start to treat each other
equally and respectfully and give each
other a sense of dignity as individuals
uh because what we learned in the 20th
century just like the centuries before
is that when you provide people with
totalizing identity categories things
can get very ugly and very destructive
in a very quick manner yeah you know i
would say we don't have very far to go
actually we just have to start ignoring
these people i think we all got there
and then they unearthed it again we we
don't really have to do much on that
josh you're in miami as i am in miami we
live in one of the most multicultural
cities in the united states i hear as
much spanish as english
i've got a couple honduran guys working
in my kitchen right now nobody cares
who's gay nobody cares what language you
speak as long as you can figure out a
way to communicate with each other
it's all good here in america these
these are the guys who are bringing it
all back
yeah you know it's funny oliver weissman
who's an editor of the spectator he had
an essay in city journal chris's
publication a few months ago it was
about the city of miami and the title of
the essay was the least woke city in
america it's a very interesting essay i
would encourage the viewers to go ahead
and check it out and what he basically
says dave is kind of what you said here
is that
i view what's happening here in miami
what's happening here in our backyard
what's happening here kind of in florida
perhaps to go a little further in
general it really is ground zero of a
broader american realignment and what
you are increasingly seeing is hispanics
to a slight lesser extent blacks but
really kind of just working class
middle-income people all across the
country who have just totally had it
with the woke nonsense they have just
totally had it with the imperious
moralistic high-handed nature of our
purported would-be woke superiors who
refused to countenance the possibility
that their opinion might not be gospel
truth or moses descending from sinai
with the tablets i mean it is really not
that difficult to understand here but
you're really seeing it play out to your
point right here in miami i mean i will
i live walking distance from little
havana i mean you walk over there you
see maga trump 2020 trump won signs
literally everywhere you go joe biden
stuff nowhere to be found you will see a
lot of let's go brandon stuff though
there is a lot of let's go branded stuff
here floating around in florida and our
governor does refer to him as brandon